what's up guys welcome to riffing with  Griffin our new location well half the  time I think I know what's ghetto as  hell but we're gonna grow with the  process right I'm getting a backdrop and  all this stuff you know it's a slow  build I like to grow with you I want you  guys to see the growth another mics over  there so when I have guests obviously  they'll be sitting over there and I'll  be sitting here and I will be adding  stuff to this I got my games I like to  play over there and you know I got my  wand you know expelliarmus you know and  pictures of me and stuff like that and  also another special thing we don't have  on here is this is singing myself but I  really appreciate you listening to  riffing with Griffin keep watching keep  listening subscribe share and if you got  something you want to send for me I  might have a box soon and we gonna make  this happen we gonna make this bigger  and better thanks for watching  [Applause]